on the horn we will battle
now that is an exclusive sneak peek at
tonight's wait for it
dramatic new episode of the bachelor now
fans know that matt james's season
is not filmed at the iconic bachelor
mansion but
since we're here i'm gonna get to take a
little look around first though
i am joined by the man who designed it
who built it and who is now renting the
mansion
marshall harridan good morning marshall
i am noticing though i kind of brought
the roses today
not as many roses on property as we
usually see on a certain tv show do they
bring the roses in
what's the deal yes
they bring their own you live here part
of the year right so you leave when
filming happens
right when you come back do you ever
find anything weird on your property
it's usually not what gets left behind
us what's missing what's gone missing
just one particular green pot that was a
favorite it was one of two
a pot got broken i think the pool gets
used quite a lot
yes it does do you ever wonder what that
pool has seen
in its day i keep it really clean really
good filtration system
very good it's all water pool you are
now putting it up on airbnb
tell me a little bit of the numbers
what's the square footage how many
bedroom bathrooms do we have
it's right around 9 600 square feet wow
there
is seven bedrooms now eight bathrooms
it sits on 10 acres okay so marshall i
want to come and stay one night
how much am i looking at just one night
yeah probably around
six thousand dollars a night six
thousand dollars what do i get
two jacuzzis swimming pool pool table
full bar
chris harrison not included oh that's
extra
a lot marshall thank you so much
and now i get to go take the most
dramatic house tour
ever we are
inside the bachelor mansion everybody
and fans will remember
these stairs tierra infamously fell
down them during sean low season tierra
i'm in heels they seem pretty sturdy to
me
bachelor nation we are in the room known
as the tink tink room where chris
harrison comes in
does a tink tank on his glass and makes
a dramatic
announcement sorry to break this up but
it is time for our first rose ceremony
ah the pool if you didn't jump in on
night one were you even here
[Music]
now many an intimate conversation has
happened at this fireplace
i'm really hoping to get the first
impression rose but if i don't
i brought my own yeah that's sad
we are now in the master bedroom closet
and behind the scenes secret when chris
harrison isn't filming
he takes naps in here so let's see what
it's like
not bad thanks
you